all right yeah i'm back with olivia munn
and floor is lava host
rutledgewood we're going to play a
special version of
rutledge's game show right now this is
called what is it called let's show your
sign
show yourself it's called olavialavia
get it
all right here's how it works relig will
read each of us a trivia question one at
a time
if we get it right we get a point but if
olivia or i get it wrong
we have to take a shot of lava or a sip
aka hot sauce that we have here at our
zoom desks
and whoever gets the most points wins so
and in honor of olivia and me because i
love superheroes too
all the trivia questions are super
superhero themed so here we go are you
guys ready
this feels so official like that was
absolute official game show
reed that wasn't so impressive lynch i'm
in it okay
this is olavia go here we go okay
question one this one's for olivia which
film
started off the current marvel superhero
universe iron man oh
that's correct she's on the board
i'm just going to drink my water not the
hot sauce
oh show off okay man i love olivia munn
okay
a little bit of a flex there here we go
question two kelly
uh what weapon does thor carry
oh a hammer you know what i'm gonna take
a little bit of my milk
olivia oh wow
i'm lactose intolerant me too mine's
almond
oh
y'all better get right with oatley that
stuff's amazing here we go question
three
uh olivia olavia uh how many actors have
played the role of peter parker
slash spiderman in the live action films
hope you enquire andrew garfield
the new british kid he's british right
is that real is that really important
right now
you don't know how my mind works let's
just assume then
yes he's british there was well those
are the first three
but then there's more after that i'm
gonna say
live action is tv and everything it's
gotta be more let's say it's gonna be
like 10 or 15 or 20 or
15 um 10 and 12. you are totally taking
this hot sauce chicken
three drink up it was three
yes you had it then you doubted yourself
i
the thing i didn't know he was tricking
you on if that new and the animated one
counted
because i didn't well i didn't know if
you meant like back in the in the
in the like in the in the olden days was
there another one
i would have given you four but 15 is
just it's not
that's not four's neighbor okay i love
your vat of hot sauce
by the way this came from you kelly
clarkson i know i just okay well i love
that we sent you the pandemic
the costco version of
we got this sent me shot glasses
drink up oh wow boy just really slow is
this enough
you can literally sip because i
literally have to sing after this i
can't i can't
shoot this ah you're fine there it is
chase it kelly are you ready i'm ready
here we go question number four how did
the fantastic four
get their super powers um i'm gonna say
i mean i've seen kind of
a poster for it so um i'm gonna say
from from the environment something
happened with the environment
okay okay yes you've got something
that's very vague can you roll that
ball down the hill a little more okay
that was a good guess
wow um something happened with the
environment there was there was um
there was an explosion could be yes
because of something
and and and there were scientists
testing stuff and it got out
and then it hit them and then they were
affected and then they
they blew up and every check with the
judges
olivia do you buy most of that i mean
i'm gonna say i'm going to say having
seen them
i think that she did a pretty good job
and i would give it to her i believe
that they crashed back to earth
cosmic or space radiation so really you
were there
get it i didn't get it close okay all
right
i felt like you did you basically there
was a thing and then there was a problem
with it
that that feels that's integrity kelly
that's what you're feeling right now
i appreciate it you need a pickle back
you need a pickle
i'm going to start a nickelback cover
band with pickles called pickleback
that means all right
uh olivia we only got questions time for
a couple more here we go uh which
superhero does bruce banner
transform into
know this one of course you do because
you missed the last one
you got to know this one no pressure
no pressure he was a just assumed he was
a tax accountant
and then sometimes he got really just
different
turned as the kids say i don't know why
bruce thorne is
bruce banner um did you see that oh yeah
no i know it's hulk
yes yeah there we go because
i don't know why but hey you got i know
i took some milk for you because my
mouth is still on fire
all right kelly we're gonna we're gonna
give you one last one who i'm gonna i'm
gonna pick
uh what would groot say if he wanted to
tell you
he was hungry fruit exactly
he would just say groot because that's
all he says that's his one word
i am group question i love guardians of
the galaxy i love
i love them anyway that was awesome
olivia well done
my mouth is on fire still so you win
you guys are so awesome thank you so
much for playing subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going